when you walk into battle pump dogs
you actually think this cannot be a
rescue center
there's chandeliers there's velvet sofas
there's music playing there are dogs
that are happy to be here
good little noodles there's a group of
extraordinary
looking people that look like they've
walked out of a model agency
we have one thing in common
the love of dogs
hello welcome to vanderpump dogs let me
show you around because this is where it
all happens
yes we're gonna have people coming in
and we need best pour forward
this is the dog house this is where our
furry friends stay
whilst they're waiting to get adopted
we've got lots of adoptions coming in
today so lots to smile about
i think it's amazing that we're making a
show about this and
getting to tell the stories of these
rescues it's really rewarding
and here we have our retail shop we sell
toys we sell carriers everything that
you need when you
adopt your little four-legged furry
friend all the prophet
goes to support the rest of the dogs
that are waiting for adoption
and we have a doggy bakery and i have
been known to actually take a nibble out
of these myself
but of course i have to i've got my name
on it
there's one for you yes and then there's
one for me
actually they're really good and this is
where ryan and patrick
do the panda puffing a vanderpuff
entails high-priced shampoos it entails
massages
marshmallow fluff brush out deep-sea mud
baths
keratin treatments deep conditioning
treatments
anything you need so you get vanderpast
and you get a whole lot
of love anyway
come upstairs we have an office upstairs
we also have a roof deck
hello go and see some of my favorite
people oh my god
look at that place we're doing our
merchandise photo shoot and it seems
like she's not the best model but she's
getting there
that's okay these photo shoots that i
have with these dogs
are so crucial to the dog getting
adopted we get messages
all day every day about dogs
and then we have the examination room
you've got one of my favorites
who's just had a surgery let's have a
look at his leg he's doing really well
he's starting to place more weight on it
he says take me home
i know right he's very handsome maybe i
will
so then we have our roof deck the dogs
don't have to be walked on the street
they can come up here and play
good boy so we bring these dogs in we
help rehabilitate them
we do interviews to make sure they're
also getting paired with the best
families
it's a really special place easy sunny
i love you oh you see anyway
thank you for coming to vanderpump dogs
i hope you enjoyed the tour
but most importantly do check it out
vanderpump dogs is streaming on peacock
[Music]
now
you